hello the very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that - my guest
today is a man who has been described as
Germany's most unusual entrepreneur and
here he is in person
Klaus hip no smiling away marilhea
they're being called Germany's most
unusual entrepreneur thank you for
coming to the show today coming to
talking generally all the way from
Bavaria great to have you here now the
reason why Klaus hip is certainly
unusual is that besides being a very
successful entrepreneur he is also an
artist a linguist a musician and an
equestrian but the fact remains that he
is best known here in Germany for the
hip brand that's H IPP the hip brand of
organic baby food so that is the most
successful product of its kind on the
German market plus hip I told my
daughter who is 19 years old that you
were coming on the show today
can you guess what she said in response
maybe that she is still using our
products 25% of grown-ups
yea use baby food young girls of course
also elderly people and spottin and
sports people yes they eat a lot of hip
baby foods yes
extreme sports people that's interesting
well it is it's true what you said my
daughter said yes sir I have lots of
friends who still eat hip products and
the interesting thing is I mean she's a
girl yeah and a lot of her friends are
girls and they're very careful with
their diet so they're looking for
organic products that have been produced
organically you you're talking about
adults eating your baby foods yeah I'm
told that you always have a little jar
or two somewhere in your car in case of
an emergency of course I always have
some products especially in the evening
night and I get tired
it makes me fit again what's your
favorite flavor every pods apricot good
choice okay you are an entrepreneur and
you were also a musician will talk about
the musician thing a little bit later
but you have said that your your
relationship with your company is like
the relationship between a conductor and
an orchestra tell me more
yes it's better to have average
conductor than two very excellent
conductors who always discuss how to do
the thing but the conductor has to have
an idea he has to listen to the musician
he has to listen if anyone plays not
correct and he has to say we start and
then it's finished so in the business
it's the same mmm at least one person
has to say what's going on and if the
conductor is not good enough has to be
changed are you an average conductor or
a very good conductor I wasn't quite
sure what you you're saying you're an
average conductor you think very modest
I don't know you've been very successful
tell me what is your business
ethos my business your business ethos
your business philosophy our philosophy
is to have best quality yep to do no
harm to the nature okay an environment
yep do the best for our consumers which
are the babies mainly and we produced to
a price everybody can afford mm-hmm
would you say that if that's your if
that's your business philosophy is it a
typically German philosophy I think
polity is maybe typical German
philosophy but every parents want to
have best quality for the babies yeah
and so far it's good that we are a
family-owned business who is run by the
family mm-hmm
if you would have managers they could be
changed
yeah but family will stay
I see so there's a there's a difference
for you in your business philosophy
between managers and family members I
think consumers trust more family who is
responsible for the business
what do you call when people are talking
about German business in the German
business model they're very often
talking about what is called the
Middle's stunt your company's quite big
do you view yourself as part of the
German middle stunt yes we are still
middle stands yeah not the big ones and
just explain what that means the middle
town because it has been such a model
for success here in Germany and still
lays little stand means that the owner
is working operative working daily
working and responsible little stunt
actually go back in in the history of
these companies there was one a person
who started maybe in one room yeah
then the factory was built around the
house next generation they built a nice
villa the up next to the victory next
generation the owners went to town hmm
and left the factory alone yeah but
middle son has to look that the owners
always in close contact to the company
so in a lot of ways middle stand means
pretty much the same as family-owned and
family run company I think so yes
so you're a linguist you're an
equestrian a musician an artist and an
entrepreneur and suddenly in this report
we discover that you were a stuntman
yeah yes it was a very good time during
my time at the university yeah I did not
have much pocket money but as something
I earned money it was a nice job for me
did you get injured no not you were a
good stuntman you were good you were
good at what you were doing I was lucky
let's go back to the beginning of the
hip family yeah of the hip family
company yeah because you were talking
about how it is a family company and the
idea to manufacture baby foods that's a
good story just tell us again where that
came from actually my grandfather
started 1899 yeah grandfather had eight
children sick twins and breastfeeding
was a problem for grandmother yeah and
he was baking some kind of cake before
it's be back in Germany no we use the
same word in English three back means
means baked twice so it makes its a
really crispy kind of toast yes and this
was Milt and mixed this water and me hmm
and versa excellent baby food and my
father started also this as a handcraft
man yeah and 1932 he started as an
industry that's interesting that you
mentioned your father because his role
in your life was very very important I
think you had a very close relationship
with your father you said that he his
education the way he educated you was
the education of a wise man that's a
wonderful thing to say about your
father's education of a wise man it was
very strong education very often I did
not agree but mm-hmm
I think it was necessary for me what do
you mean when you say I mean when you
say strong I think you mean sort of
strict yeah straight yes and not so much
freedom as I wanted to have he had the
same problem he told me mm-hmm
he also wanted to have more
freedom his father was also strict hey
it doesn't sound like much fun to me I
mean I have a quote from you I was
brought up I was brought up you say to
be aware of my responsibilities that's a
heavy word responsibility from an early
age yeah yes that began really when
there were children mm-hmm father that
you are responsible for the people for
the babies yeah and the families of
course it's also important but first of
all you have to look for things you are
doing but you want it to be a painter
your father was skeptical he was
skeptical my father was a good painter
to hear his first money was pictures oh
really
from this money he bought his first long
trousers yeah and he said to me you
never know whether you are good enough
but to be average it's not so fun but
here you have a good business and to the
art beside the business I think it was a
good decision for me it's better to have
limited time for painting it's a lot of
ideas yeah than to have many time and no
ideas you're a person who needs a lot of
discipline in your life I am beginning
to understand I think you need structure
yes and I need for my nature I'm Daisy
you're lazy but what time do you get up
each morning each and every day
half-past four half-past four Mississip
the lazy man yeah you another quote
something else that you have said about
yourself about your style as an
entrepreneur or your philosophy as an
entrepreneur you have said I believe
that an entrepreneur who has faith who
believes in God who has religion
effectively has an advantage over an
entrepreneur who is an atheist I think
through yes you can have situations
where an API
can do the same as a person with faith
but you have situations where people
with face can do more they can pray they
have the hope that it will be good and
atheist cannot do it so actually from
from the from the business view the face
is strong my situation okay so what
you're talking about there really I
suppose is business ethics and your
company actually has an ethics charter
in which it says that one of the
cornerstones of your business is the
pursuit is that the pursuit of
short-term success is no good what
you're interested in is the long term
interest of your business so long term
view perspective against short termism
but the long term in a correct and good
way and no business in short term which
is not correct do we live in a do we
live in a world where there's too much
short termism there was too much and I
think now we understand that we have to
think in long term but in correct way so
you think the tide is beginning to
change yes especially young people are
interested in changing it hmm hey they
understand if you cannot go in the wavy
rent in the past okay you talk about
morals and ethics I'd like to ask you
how important is money to you money is
nice to have but it is nice to her at
the end of my life I think I have to be
responsible what I did was in money not
how much I I saved so we come back to
that word responsibility yes yeah I
still can't quite decide whether for mr.
hip where the responsibility is
liberating or whether responsibility is
a burden both both those hmm but the
burden is a burden I am used to there
after all these years
yes of carrying that burden
I think the most important word in that
report was diversity diversity is very
important especially in agriculture we
have to look that we have again
diversity in plants animals for very
often especially in animals we have
hybrid animals which have a lot of costs
where the vet which do not live as long
as animals used to live and which are
more expensive than it was in the past
and what's the role of your company in
that in what's the role for example of
your company in relation to organic
farms like the one we saw in the report
we will teach the farmers how they can
do it you teach the farmers how they can
do it yes you have specialists who go to
the farmers oh really
but of course we cannot do farming as we
did 200 years ago 100 years ago
hmm my grandmother for instance she used
to feed 50 50 chickens mmm from baby 200
days yeah she spent one hour with the
chickens every day if I calculate today
and give her for this hour 10 euro a
chest film then after a hundred days one
chicken has 20 year old matches mmm ten
year old feet hmm so for 30 year old
nobody will buy a chicken Liam times
have changed we have to find new ways
but they have to be full of respect from
nature but will you have six thousand
different suppliers yeah how many where
do they come from then where are they
based are they Bavarian is a local of a
national they are all over the world for
the world bananas in Costa Rica oh yeah
this farmers who live in the jungle hmm
and we visit our farmers they are with
GPS peak know where they are
yeah and for our fathers it's a good
thing too
Organic bananas for instance but you're
talking about your you you're saying our
farmers you're talking about them as
though you're in some sort of
cooperative relationship with them but
surely they're they're not just your
farmers they're your suppliers and you
have to buy the goods from them at a
certain price and you need that price to
be as low as possible because you are in
a tough market yes but if we make too
much pressure mm-hmm you do not get the
quality we need and we have contracts
with the farmers mm-hmm the contract is
good for the farmer he knows surprise he
gets and we know we have suppliers you
can trust mm-hmm and this theorem is the
market in Germany big enough for all
these organic farmers still it sounds
like just for you 6,000 organic farmers
some of them outside Germany that's not
that's a lot of farms a lot of farmers
the number of organic farmers will grow
mm-hmm I think in the future you will
get some problems now with regulations
especially for small farms with cattle
Thanks
if we cannot do it in one country mmm we
do it in another country you are viewed
it's interesting we're talking about
these organic farmers because you were
you were one of the first people or you
were certainly a pioneer in Germany for
organic farming and that began at a very
early age when you I don't know what a
teenager yeah where did that come from
that idea idea came actually from
Switzerland
my mother was Swiss and in Switzerland
he made definitely hmm and therefore we
used wheat and apples from organic farms
okay and dr. Hans Muller he was actually
the pioneer of organic farming hmm
he was my mentor and teacher and even
when I went to school he said you have
to make baby food with organic products
you know and then we changed our farm to
a banach and that was your big idea in
life really you said we got we're going
to produce organic fully organic more or
less baby foods and that was your your
big idea no in those days my parents
were still alive saw
so their idea but mmm I did it all my
love yeah and it's interesting that here
in Germany people think of Germany as a
green country in many ways and the
that's linked in part to the Green Party
in the history of the Green Party and a
lot of the organic movement in Germany
came from southern Germany from where
you are from Barton Burton Bergen
Bavaria and a lot of those people were I
don't know
partly green partly conservative and
when I look at you I'm wondering does
that describe you a you sort of half
conservative half green I think a lot of
the green people we brought up already
this organic baby food maybe that's a
reason why they read so enthusiastic but
I think to do organic farming
you must not join a party you must not
be political you do it for the nature
you guys let's come from the other
direction you're talking about the
prices and this fair balance that you
have with the organic producers what
about I mean Germany's well known for
companies like you know Aldi and Lidl
who are spreading out across Europe for
sure and they they are going for
rock-bottom prices they're putting the
they're putting their suppliers under
massive massive pressure what do you say
to that because I mean they're giving
people what people want what people want
most people is cheap food products
that's specially in Germany it's a lot
soy in France if not so in other
countries but for the children people
want quality and I think that's a market
where the price is important but not so
important yeah then it is in other
markets your your products are a little
bit there like a third more expensive I
would say other than the most of your
competitors expensive yes but your
leader people are willing to pay the
extra price yeah okay something
different uh have you ever heard of a
man called out of France free douche
Ludvig [ __ ] well probably not I guess
he was a member of Germany's minor
nobility in the second half of the 18th
century and he is still remembered
because in 1788 to be precise he
published an influential book on
etiquette called on human relations
let's find out now how Knigge 'he's
example is being followed today in the
company of the wonderfully named [ __ ]
society for modern manners this is an
etiquette seminar taking place in a
luxury hotel in düsseldorf the 17
participants want to learn everything
there is to know about good manners
practice starts with fake bread and
plastic lobsters but I really never
thought about before was that are not
just learning manners but also how to
give instead of taking and expecting
things
ba-bump who runs the seminar says
etiquette means above all abiding by one
golden rule it's about mutual respect
proper etiquette makes life more
pleasant that's living for food on Kang
when Baron Adolf Nagar wrote his book on
human relations in 1788 he never could
have imagined his name would become
shorthand for showing respect and good
manners in Germany especially because
the books 450 pages contain no hard and
fast rules on etiquette literary scholar
karl-heinz gotit has studied Kennedy's
work he says it's more of a sociological
treatise infused with the spirit of the
Enlightenment novena at some point it's
snow balled in a way that connect it did
not live to see and didn't expect
because in a way he wrote the first
advice book and then came all the others
branding themselves as [ __ ] in Germany
Kanika has long been synonymous with
etiquette books nearly every bookshop
here has works on manners that use his
name
if you've mastered Knigge you're ready
for any occasion
and that has little to do with the
historical Caniggia hood of my son he
perfectly frank these people haven't the
slightest idea about connect they should
look at his words he wrote eight novels
and essays about content and literature
he produced every form of written works
of his day we have an edition of his
collected works in many volumes and
nobody knows of it worse nobody's read
it would follow my doesn't even believe
courses based loosely on Knigge are
still in great demand in Germany even
226 years after his book was first
published and one thing remains good
manners must be learned is that true
good manners must be learned or are good
manners in the blood you want you have
to want to have good manners mm-hmm a
little bit you can run yeah but I think
you'll have to have it in your heart in
your heart yes okay so it's not in the
blood and it's not out there it's in the
heart down here yeah we're talking about
mr. Knigge
and his books from all those years ago
1788 when there when his famous book
came out do you have one of the Knigge
originals at home no no okay but
nevertheless you were inspired to write
your book yeah called atom and stunt yes
I tried her and I talked to my English
colleagues about how we're going to
translate the title and it wasn't very
clear it sort of beware yeah
because of an stamp what is an stamped
it's a very very very very very German
word yes translated maybe what what is
it describing to live in a way that you
treat other people in the way you won't
be treated from them okay no that's a
very Christian interpretation or plant
yeah or can't Immanuel Kant the German
philosopher yeah okay
Arthur Germans if we're if we're saying
that this has got you know somehow
related to a manual account and we're
talking about how people behave good
manners are the Germans are good and
well-mannered a lot
I think in every country you find good
and bad oh that's not good enough you
did it you wrote a book about angst and
you wrote a book about good manners
because you're not happy about how
people are yes I think things change and
some years ago we didn't have the big
black four-wheel drive from class who
think the road is only for them okay so
you you are not a fan of SUVs they might
be necessary in in the country yeah but
not in your tongue
okay yeah but what I want to say is that
some people behave in the car mmm in a
way which is not correct mm-hmm but they
feel safe to have the car around what
does that tell us about German society
maybe some people feel stronger mmm as
long as they have strong car well okay
let's get away from the cars you said
that you are unhappy about greed egoism
and a dog-eat-dog mentality you know can
you describe that but I need you to
describe that for me what what what are
you so angry about what are you so
unhappy about are we talking about
business here we're talking about sort
of people on the streets I think we have
some people who live like Nicky yeah and
I think if if we do everything as it is
written in the book it's okay mm-hmm and
we have other people who have no idea
about all this but they do it products
further want to help other people they
want to feel the way other people feel
hmm and what I want to say is lift more
as you feel it that it's good for for
the other people and as long as we do
this we do not make mistakes big mistake
yeah not big mistakes I mean you know
you we were talkin sort of greed and and
a dog-eat-dog mentality especially a lot
of people have talked about that in the
recent times around the financial
situation the way companies are run in
Germany and elsewhere and I mean you
know what one reads in in the in the
German press that the CEO of the German
company folks wagon yeah earns 400 times
as much as an average employee that
cannot be good that's a big difference
yes and I think the so-called off seat
fat mmm the the Supervisory Board was it
they are responsible for what the
salaries and there are a lot of good
people in Germany who could do the job
you have to have more competition in
these positions when I first began to
come to Germany and got to know German
society it was very much an egalitarian
society people were trying to be sort of
more or less on the same level with each
other and now people say Germany's
becoming much more of a class Society
would you agree with that a little bit
yes but in other countries for instance
Russia hmm it's much much bigger the
difference yeah we have such a limited
shift the social market economy I was
wondering when you were going to mention
that yes and I think that's a good
system he have competition yeah we have
a social component yeah that the song
has to help so weak yeah but he have
also to protect the strong that they
didn't have all the job mm-hmm
interesting interesting insights there I
think you're talking about a society
where the word solidarity still has a
meaning yeah but it's changing fast
when most people think of Bavaria and
they think of Opera Festival they think
of course of of by Reuter they think of
the Varga festival I think it's fair to
say yeah your festival is very very
different tell me why tell me about the
spirit of the festival first of all it's
on the country yeah and people like to
be on the country and we have a lot of
people who cannot go to buy right too
expensive and too exclusive if you have
the money it's very difficult and
evening here has a very good catering
singers busy musicians for hours mm-hmm
singers sing after the Opera yeah and
it's a very close contact 16,000 people
come and enjoy the good food in the good
contact with the musicians each year who
are they are they from nearby Munich or
are they real locals are they from
across Germany there are locals but they
also some from everywhere yeah who use
the time to make holidays for it's a
nice area
near the mountains mm-hmm and if I come
to the your festival next year where am
I going to stay it is there is that lots
of sort of local accommodation there are
very nice hotels in there in the little
town itself yeah there are a lot of
places they make kimchi is five minutes
from there and enough photos I just want
to ask you the man behind it all is
Ludvik ball man he's quite ER he was
quite a well-known sake it's quite a
well-known singer just tell us a little
bit about him because he's an
interesting character he was a singer
and she come from this area yeah he had
an accident so he has to finish in Korea
mm-hmm and then he starts it there hmm
so he decided to if he can't go out and
do operas gonna have his own Opera
Festival in his back garden more or less
yeah wonderful and what and you're your
role you you're a sponsor yeah but you
also get really involved artistically I
do the scenery is my students uh-huh
every year one opera and for my students
it's very
useful to be active to see how it really
goes mmm but they do not have only
little marketers and models they can do
it themselves
wonderful and what we talk about I mean
that's you that's you as I mean involved
in music which is what you are you also
play in an orchestra but you're also you
as the artist you are a professor for
art at Tbilisi art college or university
and at state art academy the state art
academy how did that come about it's an
unusual step for a Bavarian entrepreneur
is that it in the orchestra in Munich
mmm playing second oboe the first Oh
voice distortion and he asked me to help
for disabled children in his country
with food and then they organised
exhibition for my pictures yeah
then director of Academy asked me to
teach for they had 80 years only
association with a realism and social
realism where they wanted to get some
new ideas and I did this mmm that on
University asked me so I did both okay
and you speak Russian I've mentioned
that you're a linguist you speak very
good Russian and I know that you are now
in the process of learning Georgian
properly yeah working very hard I see
you've got your notebook with us now yes
in Georgian and I I write things I have
to learn all this in my notebook here
yeah wonderful
god what a diligent what a diligent man
he is mr. hip was telling me class it
was telling me before the show that the
georgian script originated from from the
the the the the plant of the vine yeah
because it has the same shape that was
good georgia was one of the first
countries in the world ever to have
vineyards absolutely wonderful the
amazing thing is that you were born in
1938 yeah and now in 2014 you're
learning a foreign man
which you're running Georgian yeah what
does that tell us about you it's it's
very difficult and I think I'm mostly
good in languages but it's a hard job oh
yeah
he's told us he's not a very good
entrepreneur an average conductor and
all this kind of thing today it's all
not truth been a fantastic gets Klaus in
I would say is a man of conviction and
passion if you've enjoyed his company as
much as I have come back next week until
then bye bye punches
you